(triumphant musical fanfare)
(gentle music)
(upbeat music)
(saws scraping)
- What ya looking at?
- Nothing.
What's that for?
- For nothing.
Next time ya want to look at
me, line forms to the right.
Two bits admission.
- Oh Monk, what do ya want us to do?
Walk around you with blinkers on?
- I don't want guys
looking at me, special,
like it was the first time they see me.
You see this?
- Yeah but I got one too.
- Any time you want to use
it, my office is in the gutter
and next time you take
a special look at me
think of this, suddenly
you don't see Monk,
you see stars.
Eh you push the saw for a while.
Copper?
- No it's cold out there.
- Then stay in here.
If it's too cold for you,
it's too cold for the law.
After all he's only
wearing woman underwear
and a 15-pound overcoat.
- Yeah but what if one does come by?
- Angelo take it from me,
the law won't make it.
There's too much
interference on this block.
First he stops the Pacino saloon,
on a cold day the law needs a shot.
- All right big shot, cut the flapping
and give me a hand here.
Mine's falling off.
- Come on Joey.
- [Joey] Yeah, okay Monk.
(saws scraping)
- Good evening, boys.
- What do you want Father?
- I swore to myself I'd never let anything
in this neighborhood surprise me
but tell me in the name of Heaven
what are you gonna do with a staircase?
We're freezing Father,
freezing we are all of us all.
- Oh this is for firewood
but this is just kindling.
- So we use this up, so we get more.
- Well what about the tenants
who still live in the building?
But you are destroying
the landlord's property.
- Look Father, this is
a condemned tenement,
you know what that means?
Any rent the landlord gets
from this trap is velvet.
- [Father] But you're breaking the law.
- Nobody's seen us, nobody but you.
- Listen boys, I've got a
better way for you to keep warm.
In the basement of the church
there's some gym equipment,
boxing gloves, wrestling
mats, punching bag,
even shower baths.
It is also steam-heated.
You're all welcome.
- So great,
what about the old man, the old lady?
They're freezing too.
- I'm sure they'd rather stay cold
then get hot digging up
bail money for you boys.
- Okay Father, you make sense.
We'll go over to the church.
You can't talk for all of Billy Goats
without us taking a vote on it.
- Who says I can't?
- I say--
- Boys!
Settle it your own way
but do it peacefully.
Remember the invitation is for all.
I am new at St Dominic's
and this might be a chance
for us to get acquainted.
I'll be looking for you.
- Before we go we might as
well divvy up the wood we got.
What goes here?
A minute ago we had a whole stack of wood.
(playful music)
- Hey Monk, that's mine.
I took 'em on my own time
from Brushetto's Market.
- That's what you get
for holding out on us.
(playful music)
- Anybody care for some mustard?
- He's late again.
I don't like it.
I don't like my son to become bandido.
- Be calm Gino.
Maybe he's look for wood.
- Yeah.
The way he's looking for
wood, he find trouble.
Where you steal that bandido?
- Paul, did you steal it?
- No, always you think the worst of me.
Some day I'm going to--
- Don't talk back!
Said keep still!
- You hit me once more,
you'll never see me here no more.
- Please, please!
- No Mama Mia.
This was given to me by the
new priest at St. Dominic's.
I helped him clean out the church.
(speaks in foreign language)
- Then it's alright.
- I had some wood I'd give to Angelo.
(gentle music)
- This new priest, he's Irish, huh?
- Yeah, he's a young guy.
- Why not stay with his own people?
Little Italy is for Italians.
- Gino, do not speak so of a priest.
He's give us coal.
Maybe he's get a job for Paulo, huh?
- Yeah.
- And he's teaching me.
- Lord, bless you.
And through us.
(Paul praying quietly)
- This is priest, what
he teaching, you, huh?
- Oh, things.
- He explain the good book to you.
He makes you say over
the 10 Commandments, huh?
- What's the difference?
He's teaching me.
(gentle music)
(traffic humming)
- Here let me show you.
- Oh, go ahead.
- Only a mutton head would
get mad at a punching bag.
It isn't as if it had a will of its own.
- It's tricky.
- Only because you don't how to handle it.
First you sort of coax it.
- I'll never be any good
at this coaxing stuff.
- Well you'll have to learn.
All you boys around here
think fighting means killing somebody.
- That's right.
This block you turn your head
you're just asking for it.
- But the science of boxing
will teach you that--
- Aw, you don't have to
teach me how to fight.
I can take care of myself.
- In a street brawl.
- On the roof, in a dark
hallway, the subway,
the park, anywheres.
- Wherever there's three of you to one.
- I don't need any extra help.
- Good, perhaps you'd
like to prove it to me.
Angelo.
- Yes, Father.
- Oh, I wouldn't lay a hand on no Father.
- Well I'm glad to see that
you have so much respect for the cloth
but just the same I
think you're about ready
for your first boxing lesson, come on.
- Look Father, I don't want to fight ya.
I'll hurt ya or something.
- He'll hurt you, Father.
- He sure will!
He hits so hard.
- You let me worry about that.
You just try to take care of yourself.
We're trying to prove that a
human being can protect himself
without killing his opponent.
Come on, get on to the mat and
fight like a man, not an ape.
- [Paul] Just remember
Father, you asked for it.
- Come on, Monk.
- [Paul] Father I gotta know,
what did you hit me with?
- That my boy was sort of an
extracurricular part of
my religious training,
better known as a left jab.
It has a definite value
convincing certain types of unbelievers,
convinced your friends, it convinced you.
- [Paul] Will you teach me that?
- Indeed I will.
Sometimes in anger one forgets the Lord
but never the knack of throwing a left jab
and Paul, I called you
Monk to prove a point.
You're gonna have to live with the face,
I know you're sensitive about your looks
but your face is God's dispensation
and you can't escape it
by brutally beating up
everything in the world that
looks at you or dislikes it.
- Yeah, I guess so Father.
(gentle music)
It's just that I get mad
anytime anybody makes cracks.
When I was a kid none of the
other kids would play with me.
The neighbors would look at me
like I had the evil eye or something.
Father, I'm 19 years old going on 20.
Nobody can look at me straight,
no girl even comes near me.
Angelo's the only one
ever really was my friend,
face and no face.
Tell me Father Callaghan,
don't it make you feel
different to have to talk to me
and look at this?
- No, no I can honestly
say it makes no difference.
Paul, a man's face is
such an external thing,
like his skin being red, or
brown, or black, or white,
like his hair being long or short.
These things are the covering of a man
and after all I'm mainly concerned
with the deepest inside part of it.
Many people suffer because
their, their color,
or their size, or their shape,
or the kind of face
they have is different,
but the most important
thing to remember is this,
if you hate your face
because they hate it,
if you call yourself ugly
because some ignorant man called you ugly,
you're just as guilty as he is, guilty.
You simply have no right
to be so intolerant,
even of yourself.
Only Fools would laugh at you
but you mustn't help
them by losing your head
and besides I don't think your
face is so ugly as all that.
After all I'm no beauty myself. (laughs)
And anyway, underneath it all
I think you're a pretty
nice guy, Paul Baroni
and that's a lot more important
than being just pretty,
and if you'll drop back tomorrow
why I'll show you exactly what hit you.
(gentle music)
- Now only a mutton head would
get mad at a punching bag.
You gotta coax it.
Stay with it you'll catch on.
Now all you guys are gonna
learn how to fight proper like,
off with the coat, Pete, you're next.
- Aw no, Monk.
- Come on, come on.
(wood thuds)
Now there'll be none of that Pete.
Father Callaghan was good
enough to let us use the place,
so leave the stuff alone.
All right, let's go.
Put up your guard.
Now don't drop your guard
just because I faint, try it again.
- Yeah but suppose I drop a
milk bottle on ya from the roof,
What good's this?
- We'll see.
Now you see, sometimes
there's no milk bottle handy,
a left jab is your best friend.
- [Pete] Yeah.
- And this is our gym Miss Brooks.
Perhaps in time we can use
this as a recreation hall.
- It's large enough.
Of course you'll have to get some games
and some new equipment.
- You mean some new patrons.
Boys this is Miss Brooks,
who's coming down evenings to
work with our social program.
- Hi.
- Hello.
- Paul would you come here a minute?
I particularly want to
introduce you to Paul Baroni.
He's going to help me with
our physical culture program.
- Oh.
- Pleased to meet you.
- Thank you.
I guess you and I will
be working together.
- Well I, I guess so.
(Paul laughs)
- Wow you couldn't do that last month.
- That's right Fater.
What's that for?
- That's for calling me Fater.
Well we talked about this before.
You read the books I give
you without any trouble
but you still persist in
talking East 106th Street.
I know it's part of your
mechanism of being tough
but with my own ears I have
heard you pronounce words
like a human being.
- Well, hymns and prayers is different.
They're all printed in English
and if you can say father in church
you can pronounce it correctly elsewhere.
- Okay Fater.
(traffic humming)
- Now we can get out of the business.
Tell me, what's eating you?
- What?
- Don't try to kid me.
You've been fiddling around
here for the last half hour,
talking about this and that.
Let's stop beating around
the bush and get to it.
- Okay Father, I'll
give it to you straight.
I've been watching the services,
you know, listening and everything,
like I told you it gets
me, especially the singing.
Father, if you think I could
I'd like to try and sing in the choir.
(Father laughs)
- Of course Paul, of course.
I wasn't laughing at you
but I am impressed by your courage.
Yes, your courage
and you certainly shall get a
chance to sing in the choir,
providing of course you can sing.
Come on, we'll have the choir
master try your voice now.
- Hello, Mama.
- Ah, I see father Callahan
teach you again today, huh?
- No Mama, today I study singing.
You cutting your faced with a high C?
- No, no.
The choir master says I got a voice,
kind of rough he says, but a baritone
and they need a baritone.
You see Mama, most the
kids are 11, 12 years old,
all they got is sopranos or altos.
Me, me, I'm a man.
I got a man's voice
and tomorrow Mama for the first time
I get to sing with the regular
choir in church at services.
- Paulo, that's so good,
that's so good, Paulo.
♪ Morning ♪
- Yeah, but we have rehearsal tomorrow,
so we'll see how he is.
(suspenseful music)
- Huh.
What do you take Tony?
Is it a dame or maybe it's
just Father Callahan's stooge?
- Why don't you guys beat it.
This is no place for a beef.
- Huh, ain't he pretty.
- Where'd you get the skirts Monk?
- We don't want a beef,
we would like a dance.
How 'bout a date, Monk?
- Where's your organ grinder, Monk?
You got the face and the skirts for it.
All you need now is a tin cup.
- Monk!
You don't want to get
your lace panties dirty.
- Hold it, will ya?
- What's the matter Angie?
You losing your nerve?
- Listen you guys, Monk
ain't done nothing to nobody.
- What do you mean he ain't done nothin'?
He quit, didn't he?
You know we got a rule,
nobody quits the Goats,
not and gets away with it, huh fellas?
- That's right.
- Yeah.
- Now look at him, Callahan's sissy,
and we let him push us around, tough guy.
Monk Baroni, look at him.
Come on, fellas, let's get him.
(suspenseful music)
(boys screaming)
Ow!
Uh, ow!
(boys grunting)
- Paul!
- What did I do?
- Monk.
- It was an accident, I didn't mean it.
It was an accident.
- Help, murder, help police!
- Monk, get going, Monk.
You gotta get outta here.
- It was an accident.
- Look, Monk, you ain't kid.
Nobody's gonna believe
it was any accident.
The cops still remember ya.
Father Callahan ain't gonna be here
to put in a good word for ya.
Monk you gotta get out of
here, to the coal yard!
Hide there, I'll come later tonight.
Now get going.
(suspenseful music)
(whistle blowing)
(somber music)
(train whistling)
(suspenseful music)
- Angie, Angie.
- Monk, I'm glad I found ya.
Here's some chocolate and your coat.
It's all I could get.
- How is he?
- Go ahead and eat.
They took him to the hospital.
He's hurt but he's okay.
- You sure?
- Sure.
Monk you got to stay away off the block.
You can't go home.
- The only guy ever did me a good turn
and I sent to the hospital.
This kisser of mine, this Ape's face.
Monk, Monk Baroni, it's a curse.
It's a curse from God.
It's bad luck for everybody I know.
- Shh, Monk, hold it down.
You gotta get a hold of yourself.
We gotta figure what you're gonna do.
- With this face and these
fists, what can I do?
(audience chattering)
(whistle blowing)
(bell ringing)
(audience shouting)
- [Audience Members] Boo!
Boo, Boo!
Boo!
- One, two, three, four.
- [Audience Members] Boo!
- [Audience Member] Get up.
- Boo!
- Get him, come on, get up!
- Throw him out!
- [Audience Member] Boo!
- Hey, where your table manners?
It's customary for a winner to help carry
his defeated upon to a corner.
- Boo.
- Come on.
- Defeated opponent you can
lay there for all I care there.
They're booing me not him.
- [Audience Members] Boo!
(audience shouting)
- What kind of watch
they give us this time?
- Same kind.
Imitation gold.
(Monk scoffs)
- When we gonna finish with this imitation
and get into the real stuff?
- Soon, I hope.
- Well it's good for four bucks.
Say you and me split a steak
and then we split a pool table.
Someday we get twin beds.
(glass taps)
- Oh no, oh no, don't,
don't tell me you're
bringing me another watch?
- That's all they give us.
- The other guy's silly,
you bust a knuckle,
all you get is a gold watch.
- All these watches
ticking away in my safe,
they're driving me crazy,
even if I can't hear them
they, they keep me awake.
Oh, here you are.
There's one, two, three, four.
And don't bring me any more watches.
- We can't eat the springs.
- Well and why don't you
get wise to yourself.
Come here kid.
You know, you must have
dynamite in those fists.
This is the sixth watch they've given you
in three weeks, isn't it?
- Mostly one round KOs.
- Well then, why don't you
get wise and become a pro?
- That's easy to say but how?
The gyms are crawling with golden glovers.
We don't know anybody on the West Side.
Who do you see, who do you talk to?
- All right, so listen and I'll tell ya.
Now you go up to Griffin's Private Gym,
10th Avenue and 48th Street.
Walk-up one flight.
(traffic humming)
(punching bags slapping)
- This is it.
- Yeah here's the saloon.
(punching bags slapping)
(boxers chattering)
- Say, uh, bud, who is this Mr. Hellman?
- That's him over there with the glasses.
He's reading.
Yeah, he's always reading.
(boxers chattering)
- Could we talk to you, Mr. Hellman?
- Well that would depend I should say
on your arrange of conversation.
What would you like to discuss?
- Somebody told us to ask for ya.
- How cozy.
- But we're not supposed to say who.
- Well if you tell me who, I might listen.
That's the first trait I like to
find in a fighter is treachery.
The ability to betray a confidence.
- Look Mr. Hellman, we ain't
good at this double-talk
but my buddy here's got the
makings of a good fighter.
- Why come to me?
I'm a manager, I'm not a trainer.
- 'Cause Uncle won't take any
more imitation gold watches.
- You do much fighting?
- Six amateurs, won all six by knockouts.
- Look, I hate bragging,
just breathe easy boy
don't throw your chest out.
What's your name?
- Young Baroni.
- Young. (laughs)
Oh I bet that's a lie.
Why even those penny-ante fans
support those stupid amateurs
wouldn't stand still for
that physiognomy of yours
going under that banner. (laughs)
Young, hu-oh.
Why your old boy, your face is old.
It's, it's atavistic.
It's almost prehistoric.
Come on, give me the truth.
What name do you fight under?
Ape Baroni or Gorilla Baroni?
- It's monk, yeah Monk.
- You know you mustn't
hit a man with glasses.
- Then don't needle my buddy.
- Teach him to control himself.
- Then talk to us like human beings.
- Why?
Look I hate to teach anybody anything
but there's one lesson
that I'll teach you,
never lose your temper except in the ring.
To most fighters I say
never lose your temper,
especially in the ring
but you, if you ever fight for me
that's where I want you to lose it.
I want you to snarl,
spit, show your fangs.
I want a real primitive show, Monk Baroni.
- Okay, okay.
- Would you like to see him box?
- Well you said he'd win
his first six by knockout,
so let's see here.
Here we are.
Young Baroni, four knockouts,
two technical knockouts.
Young Baroni, well what do you know?
You boys must be new to the
fight game, you're honest.
- You mean you got a record on Monk?
- Why certainly.
If I took the word of every would-be pug
that comes in here,
I'd be spending 24 hours a
day listening to stumblebums.
Look here's 20 bucks, get
yourself a room at the Y
and supervise his training.
See that he runs around the reservoir,
does plenty of gym work.
Keep him in shape
but don't overfeed him, I want him hungry.
And sign this receipt
'cause one way or another I
expect to get my money back.
(boxers chattering)
(punching bags slapping)
- Then you're his manager?
- I'm his manager.
- How soon you want to see him?
- Keep him out of my sight
but you come back here in about a week
and I'll sign him up
for a four-round prelim
out of the Staten Island Arena.
At least I'll enjoy the ferry ride.
(suspenseful music)
(audience shouting_
(triumphant music)
(audience shouting)
(suspenseful music)
(triumphant music)
(audience shouting)
(suspenseful music)
(triumphant music)
(traffic humming)
- Hello, Mr. Baroni.
Your record from Italy
came in this morning.
Would you like to hear it?
- I sure would.
- All right, right over here.
(peaceful music)
(singing in foreign language)
- Paul, how are you?
- You, you still talk to me?
- I shouldn't for the length
of time you stayed away.
- Then you're not, you're not sore at me?
- Not sore?
Come now, Paul, even a priest is human.
When the side of my head caved in
I could have throttled you.
- Honest I didn't mean it.
My head was full of stone,
I couldn't see who it was.
I was so mad, crazy mad.
- That scratch healed in due time
but what I am angry about
is the fact that you stayed away so long.
- I was ashamed.
- I did get your conscience money
for the choirboys clothes.
In fact, I was able to
get six complete outfits.
- [Paul] That helps.
- I saw Angelo slipping
the money in the poor box.
He wasn't very clever
about sneaking it in.
I saw him but I wouldn't go near him.
I wanted you to come
forward, not your stooge.
- [Paul] I, I just didn't have the nerve.
- It's all wiped out.
- Thanks.
- I see you're still
interested in church music.
- You got the goods on me.
- Yes and I intend to club you with it.
Paul I'm gonna send off a letter
to every sports writer in New York.
I can see the headlines now,
welterweight trains on Gregorian chants.
Yes I'm gonna resort to blackmail
if you don't come up and see us.
- You mean I can?
- I mean you must.
Why you ungrateful wretch.
Who do you think taught you
how to throw a left jab?
Every time I connect what I say,
"Here's a message from Father Callahan."
- And you've been connecting, huh?
I've been reading about you.
Well here are your orders.
This very Saturday night,
in the gym where you first
learn to coax a punching bag
we're having a dance for
the friends of St. Dominick.
- A dance?
- Oh yes, we've made a lot of progress.
You haven't seen the place in over a year,
you'll be delighted.
- I'll come.
- It'll cost you two bits.
- I'll pay at the door.
- Bring a girl.
- Ain't got one.
Well, huh, who's your manager?
- Four-eyed buzzard, name of Mr. Hellman.
- Bring him.
- He's my manager, not my friend.
(peaceful music)
I found out one thing,
in this racket you got no friends.
That's why when I'm alone
I'm glad I can listen to
a little church music.
- I'm proud of you Paul.
You've grown, you've
matured, you've got values.
You'll be all right.
- I still get my block knocked off.
- You'll be all right.
If not as a fighter, as a man.
You know, you're somewhat of a celebrity
up on East 106th Street.
We'll all be glad to see ya.
Saturday.
- Okay Fater.
(Paul chuckles)
(peaceful music)
(guests chattering)
(twinkling piano music)
- Welcome home, Paul.
How are you Angelo?
- Just fine, Father.
It's good to be back.
- Place looks great.
- Oh this is just a start.
Someday perhaps we'll have
a recreation all big enough
for everyone in the community.
- How are the kids taken to it?
- That's where the real progress lies,
kindness can perform miracles.
- You're telling me.
- Well make yourself at home boys,
there's plenty of sandwiches,
and cookies, and fruit,
and, well I'm afraid you're a little late.
There was plenty of
refreshment there a minute ago.
- Excuse me.
(playful music)
Hi Pete, it's been a long time.
- Hi Monk.
- Just a second, Pete.
(playful music)
Things don't change much, do they Pete?
But nice bumping into you, Pete.
(playful music)
- Ah that Pete.
I still have a ways to go with him.
Did you hear about him burning his coat?
- Say, I did notice his coat
had a small patch on it.
- That's it.
As near as I can understand it,
Pete was borrowing one of the
candle holders from the alter
when someone came in the door.
Now this caught Pete by surprise,
so he put the holder inside of his coat
while the candle was still burning.
(Paul and Angelo laughing)
- Well this sounds like a happy group.
- Boys, you remember Miss Brooks.
- Hi.
- Hello.
- You're a little late.
We were supposed to work together
here at st. Dominic's remember?
- I took a holiday.
- Dance?
- Oh thanks but Father
Callahan and Angelo were
and I we were just--
- I'm leaving.
- I've already left.
- Looks like your excuses
have run out on you.
(gentle music)
You're light on your feet.
Must be the road work I'm doing,
once around the reservoir every morning.
That accounts for endurance
but not for a sense of rhythm.
- Then it must be punching the bag.
- But you're not dancing on your hands.
- Well then it's skipping rope.
- Will you quit shadow boxing,
you're just naturally graceful
and don't be ashamed of it.
It's much better than being awkward.
I can tell a born dancer, you coordinate.
- Oh, that's what I do.
- And don't pretend you don't understand.
Father Callahan said you know
much longer words than you use
and you can pronounce
all of them correctly.
He also said you're a secret reader,
the way some people nip on the sly.
- Okay Miss Brooke's,
you got the goods on me.
I'll go quiet.
- I called you Paul.
- Then, to you I'll speak different.
(gentle music)
- Paul?
- Yeah?
- Can I see you fight sometime?
- No ma'am, never.
You asked me, Emily, so I told ya.
- Well you didn't have to
answer with your left jab.
- I'm sorry
but if you saw me in the ring,
a girl like you wouldn't go
for that sort of business.
It's no good.
(upbeat music)
You can do better than that.
(gentle music)
- That's right, you do enjoy good music.
- That Father Callaghan's
been talking again.
- It's no crime to enjoy fine music, Paul.
It's the key to a number
of good pleasures.
After that you enjoy
good books, good food,
good conversation, good
people, and good relationships.
- Like the ones I haven't known.
Emily, don't tell me
a pretty girl like you
doesn't have plenty of boyfriends.
- If you're trying to find out
if I've been sitting
around waiting for you
well, I'll have to admit I
do go out on other dates.
- You may get the chance
to see me fight yet.
(Emily laughs)
(bell ringing)
- [June] Hiya handsome.
- Hi.
One roll to see if I win ya.
- [June] Didn't you know,
dice are always loaded in my favor.
- [Paul] Two pair.
- Three of a kind,
- [Paul] Guess, I don't
make the grade tonight.
- Not with this hand.
So long chap.
(gentle music)
(singing in foreign language)
(door knocks)
(upbeat jazz music)
- I told Angelo I was coming over.
- He mentioned it but never said when.
- Right now.
Since we're alone I'll get
right down to the point.
Monk, I bring you good tidings.
The Mysteriosos Of Cauliflower Rally,
those slick, soft-spoken gentlemen
that they refer to as The Syndicate
are interested in ya.
- What does that make me?
- Well makes ya a
candidate for big purses.
- How big?
- Depends on how well you draw
but you ought to draw well
because you're in for a
big publicity build-up.
Look monk you're gonna
fight main events in cities
where normally they use
club fighters like you
for curtain raisers and
pretty soon the garden.
So if you live sensibly, which you won't,
and stay away from fascinating dames,
which you probably can't,
you'll have some money left to live on
after your punched silly.
- Where does this switch leave you?
- Me, oh I'm still your manager.
I take a smaller cut but
then it's a bigger pie
and fronting for The Syndicate
makes certain the pie is on the table.
- Mr. Hellman, I can see
you put up a big battle
before you hollered Mama.
- Monk, I leave the
heroics to my fighters.
They're better equipped for it.
I didn't come into this game
to go out with any medals.
I was attractive to the cash.
No reporter will ever quote me as saying
I did it for the good of the game
or because I enjoyed the companionship
of punch-drunk gargoyles.
- I'd like to take one good swing at you.
- Obviously, but you won't
change my way of thinking.
Monk, I'll tell you something.
I may be selfish but I'm honest
and I call all the cards
even when they're marked.
- I don't like you.
I don't understand you.
- Keep it that way, you'll be better off.
- Okay.
What do we do about this syndicate?
- We see them.
- When?
- Right now.
And Monk, one word of advice
don't act conceited with these gentlemen.
They don't want you because
you're a great fighter.
- Then why tag me?
- I told you they're smart.
They, they balance the
fighters they control.
They never match similar
boys, that would be boring.
Public wants variety.
The clever counter-puncher
against the slugger,
the Hell's Kitchen lowbrow
against the college waltzer,
variety, dream pussies, angel faces,
gentleman boxers, killers.
- What am I supposed to be?
- (clears throat) Well they didn't tell me
but I understand what they
need is a real dirty fighter.
- How'd you get that?
I was fighting Pretty
Boy Jones in New Haven.
- He wasn't pretty when
they carried him out.
- Oh, give me the lowdown, how?
- Well Monk, before we tag anyone
we have the boy watched carefully.
You were scouted
and one of our men took these
pictures with a hidden camera.
We've had them blowing up and
slowed down for your benefit.
- You saw the winner.
- I sure did.
- Don't forget him Monk Baroni,
that's the fighter we buy
and from here in that's
the way you fight .
- Hey Monk, Monk come
here a minute will ya?
You're fighting Sailor
Jetson in Newark next week.
- How does he look?
- Hot.
You know, that's a funny
thing you never ask me
can he punch, is he
fast, what's his reach,
is he strong, it's
always how does he look?
- That's all I'm interested in.
- Well I'll tell ya, the,
the Sailor's a good-looking,
clean-cut, blond boy.
- I'll fix that.
- You hate every man you fight, don't ya?
- Just evening up a score, that's all.
(punching bags slapping)
- Ladies and gentlemen,
this is the main event.
In the black corner,
wearing purple trunks,
weighing in at 167 pounds, Monk Baroni.
(crowd booing)
(bell ringing)
And here in the white
corner, wearing gold trunks,
and 170 pounds, Sailor Jetson.
(crowd cheers)
- Now you boys both know the rules
laid down by the Athletic Commission.
I want a nice clean fight
and if a fighter gets knocked down
I want the other fighter to go to
the farthest neutral corner.
Now shake hands and come out fighting.
(crowd shouting)
(whistle blowing)
(bell dings)
(crowd shouting)
(powerful music)
(triumphant music)
(gentle music)
- How was this trip, Paul?
- Just one fight after another.
You want the sum total?
30 stitches, one busted
knuckle, two lose teeth,
maybe half a pint of blood, money too.
Angelo banks it.
By the time I look like a real
ape, I'll have a bank roll.
I don't know if my buildup
is good but it sure is fast.
Fans are paying more and
more to see me get slugged.
- Hurt much?
- Sure it hurts.
That's my job, to get hurt.
People pay good money to see me get hurt,
maybe get killed.
Don't feel sorry for me, Emily.
I like this plaster, the
patches, and the cuts.
They help hide my face.
Yeah, on me it looks good.
I'm glad I can wear 'em
when I have to meet you.
(gentle music)
- You don't have to wear
a mask with me, Paul.
- I know but it makes it easier.
- You hate what you're doing?
- I do.
It's not even fighting,
it's throwing a gorilla
into the ring to put on a slaughter fest.
- But you really want to be a fighter?
- What else could I do with this?
- You could change your face.
- What?
- Yes, since it's your
face that stands between
you and yourself, your
real self, change it.
- How?
- Plastic surgery.
Think of the miracles they
did during the war, Paul,
your face would be easy for them.
- But if I, if I change my face
I have to give up fighting.
- You'll be giving up what you hate.
- But I've come quite a
ways in the boxing game.
- You still despise it.
- It's money, when you never
had it before in your life
you just don't go tossing it over.
- But what good is it
when you're miserable,
hating and bitter.
You know Paul, you blame every
misfortune you've ever had
on just one thing.
- But that one thing is now
starting to pay off for me.
- But in what way?
- Sure you're living better.
But, but that anger and
resentment is still there,
maybe even more so.
- How will I make a living?
- We'll work that out.
- We?
- Yes we, you and me.
Paul when you discard that mask
you'll, you'll finally be
at peace with yourself.
Then the world will see
the real, wonderful Paul.
(gentle music)
- You tell me what to do.
(playful music)
- [Angelo] Hiya, Pete.
- Well this certainly is
an unexpected pleasure.
- [Pete] Here Monk.
- Thanks Pete but the
operation was a success.
This is a funeral wreath.
- I know but when I was shopping around,
that's all I could find.
- Uh, thanks again Pete but
you shouldn't have done it.
Say Father, have you seen Emily?
- I certainly have and I'm very
glad to hear about you too.
She's a fine girl.
Her family, they live in Buffalo.
They wrote to me inquiring about you.
I'm afraid I simply had
to tell them the truth.
After all, if it wasn't for me
you'd have never known
the difference between
a right hook and a left jab. (laughs)
One thing about Emily--
- I guess you guys have a lot
to talk over, I'm shoving.
- Thanks for everything Pete.
- It certainly was considered
of you to take time off
and come up and see an old buddy.
- So long, Pete.
- Bye.
(playful music)
- I guess I better be running along too.
- How's the gym coming?
- Fine more kids coming in every day.
- Say Father, in my condition
I can't handle any candy.
Why don't you take the box
of chocolates along with you,
for the gang at the church.
- [Father] Why it's a good idea.
I'm sure they'd appreciate.
(playful music)
(all laughing)
- [Paul] Hi.
- Hiya handsome.
Hey who punched you pretty?
- You like?
- Mm-hmm, whoever did
it sure had the touch.
- No beef from me.
One roll to see if I win ya.
- I'm tough to beat it
but it doesn't mean I'm invincible.
- Invincible, now what does that mean?
(sultry music)
- You just found out.
- Now what would I do
with a fistful of cigars?
- What else would you like?
A box of candy?
A package of playing cards?
A ballpen?
Well tell me, what else would you like?
(energetic music)
You're a swell dancer, you're graceful.
- Why not?
The roadwork I do, punching
the bag, skipping rope,
all that makes me light on my feet.
- No kidding, good looking.
You dance as if you're in another world.
- Maybe that's it.
(energetic music)
- Here it is, I guess I can let myself in.
I said myself.
- Can't I smoke a last cigarette?
- Okay the rubber mat says welcome
but don't let it fool you.
- Say this is all right.
Light it.
- You really want service.
- Maybe I rate it.
- Monk, let's get one thing straight.
Every Joe that buys a cigar from me
or rattles the dice in the cup
thinks the date goes with it.
- Well, I don't.
Took me a long time and a new face.
- So I went out with you.
The date ends on the
other side of the door.
- I don't feel like leaving.
- Please I'm a working
girl, I need sleep, rest,
to hold my job, to make it pay
off I have to be attractive.
- You mean all this and
the clothes you wear,
you win all that across the counter.
- I can't stop some of my dates
from buying me small presents.
Like that off-the-shoulder gown
we saw tonight in Bergdorf's window.
- You got it baby.
- I guess maybe you can
smoke that last cigarette.
(traffic humming)
- Angelo, get down to the bank
and bring back some scratch, huh?
- Like how much?
- Two or three C's.
- I don't think you've got that much.
- What do you mean?
- The way you've been
throwing your dough around
you're nearly all tapped out.
- (scoffs) You're crazy.
- Since you've been
hanging around with June,
here's the tab.
One evening gown, 250, one stole 600,
half a dozen pair of shoesies, 180,
assorted costume jewelry,
200, sundry items 580.
Everything's going out,
nothing's coming in.
Everything for June, nothing
for Emily, not even time.
- Why don't you mind your own business.
- Okay, okay.
- Where ya going now?
- I'm gonna take five bucks to your mom
and then I'm gonna go look for a job.
(gentle music)
- You haven't said much.
- I've been watching you watch yourself.
I guess the mirror no longer scares you.
- Not a bit.
- In fact, it fascinates
you, like hypnotism.
- Can't a guy look at himself?
- Not long enough to pass
out into a dream world.
What's come over you, Paul?
It's been three weeks since I've seen you
and when you do show up,
you're late, you're rude.
I like the old Paul better.
- Well I don't.
- You proved you don't.
We were supposed to make
plans, talk about our future.
- Give me a little time, Emily.
I'll get over this.
- I don't think so Paul.
I watched you in the hotel lobby,
on the street when we
walked, in the restaurant,
you've got no thoughts
for anyone but yourself
and the way you beg for
admiration from the girls.
- Well I never had any.
- Well from what I hear you're
making up for lost time.
- Emily nothing has changed between us.
- I don't know.
Well I'll prove it to you.
- Paul.
- You still think I look like a.
- Paul, how could you?
Do you think this new face matters to me?
- Well you act like it.
- I don't like you.
I don't understand you.
- Because I'm like any
other guy with his girl.
- Leave me alone.
(suspenseful music)
- Emily!
(sultry music)
- No, Monk.
- Can't I smoke a last cigarette?
- I told you I want to go to sleep.
- Came over you all of a sudden, huh?
- Look Monk, I don't
care for hallway scenes
so I'll make this short.
Let's say goodnight and goodbye.
- Why?
- You're in way over your head,
you can't afford to go out with me.
I like nice things
but I don't want them
out of your eating, Monk.
- I can get more.
- I want no part of trouble.
Why you even owe the
hotel last month's rent.
- Ah, that's nothing.
- Look Buster, I'm not your bookkeeper.
All I'm trying to tell ya
is that this round's over.
We had some fun, I let
you break in your new face
and this is it.
- So it's a brush, huh?
- To go out with you,
just doesn't make sense
and if anything, I'm a sensible girl.
- You might as well take
in your welcome mat.
(traffic humming)
What do you want here?
- I was worried about you.
- You ran out on me
once, leave it that way.
- Paul, I want to talk to you.
I may be going away.
- This is no place to talk.
Besides there's nothing to say.
- Emily's going away to teach.
- Fine pal.
All you think of is ways to trip me up.
Why don't you just butt
out of my business?
- Don't pick on Angelo, I
asked him to bring me here.
- Sure and he was glad to,
anything to prove I'm a no-good guy.
You're all right people,
now that I'm broke.
- You know that doesn't matter to me.
We talked about it just
before your operation.
We were supposed to plan
our future together.
You, you promised we'd work it out.
- Well it worked out fine.
I got a new face, no
friends, and I'm broke.
- Don't pip Emily, she
didn't blow your bank roll.
- I told you to butt out of this.
Get out, get out both of ya.
I don't want to be needled, get out!
- I'll take you home.
- Goodbye, Paul.
- Say, where's the clerk?
- You're out of bounds brother,
this isn't the Waldorf.
You don't happen to know
a Monk Baroni, do you?
- I did know a Monk Baroni.
- Know where I could find him?
- You're too far Uptown.
Why don't you try one of those
flea traps on the West Side of the tracks?
- [Mr. Hellman] All right, I will, thanks.
(door knocks)
Hello, Monk.
- How did you find me?
That was easy, I just followed
a trail of unpaid bills
and those fascinating dame's
that I was telling you about
have begun to crush up.
- What do you want?
- Look you've been avoiding me, what for?
I know it isn't your conscience.
- I don't want to see anybody.
- Well I wanna see you.
Well, well that's pretty.
- Save the cracks.
I had a little accident,
that's why you didn't hear from me.
When the medic patched me
up, he made a few changes.
- Few changes, huh,
I'd say that was the
understatement of the season.
- Well I vote for it.
- I don't, Monk, for me
the old face was better,
certainly a lot better for fighting.
- Maybe I ain't fighting anymore.
- Why give up the ring
just when you're ready for the big purses?
Monk when that doctor fixed your face
he certainly didn't help your brain much.
- I'm giving it up, I'm gonna retire.
- Retire on what?
Your clippings?
But Monk, you're just
hurting yourself, not us.
The cab loses a fender,
the taxi company doesn't go
out of business, does it?
And for me and my associates,
fighting his business,
business, it goes on and on.
- so I quit.
- No fighter ever quits, Monk.
Once you lace on a pair of those gloves
you make a lifelong marriage.
You never get away from it.
When you leave the stadium
at night after a fight
who sells you the morning papers?
A blind ex-pug.
You'll never get away from it
and your broken now, Monk.
So I know you'll come running back to me.
My advice is to make it soon.
My associates haven't
got too much patience.
They may find themselves
another dirty fighter.
- [Trainer] Come on champ.
- All right Monk, let's
make it short and sweet.
Remember this is your
first come back fight
and those sports writers out
there want plenty action.
Give it to them.
- Semi Windup's on, you're next.
(audience chattering)
(audience cheering)
(audience booing)
- [Audience Member] Come on, Monk!
- All right, let's go boys.
Now you boys know the rules.
I want a nice clean fight.
Keep all your punches in fair territory
and break clean when I tell you.
Shake hands now and come
out fighting at the bell.
(buzzer dings)
(bell dings)
(audience shouting)
(audience booing)
- What's come over Monk?
- Don't know, he acts like
he's been reading Emily Post.
- Well he better drop his
pinky in the next round.
(audience shouting)
- I'll whisper in his
ear that this is a fight
and not a cotillion.
- Yeah, tell him we put
a bet on a knockout.
(audience shouting)
(bell dings)
(audience booing)
- Thought he was easy to hit?
- Always was, looks like
he switched his style.
- Sure did.
- So box him.
If we both box, where's the action?
- You want a little
softer music this round?
All right you proved you
can dance, now fight.
(buzzer dings)
(bell rings)
- [Audience Member] Hey get him!
Come on, Monk.
Come on, fight, fight!
(audience shouting)
(audience booing)
Come on Monk!
- Come on, punch a little bit,
use the match, will ya?
(audience booing)
- Come on!
- Come on, fight.
(audience shouting)
(bell dings)
(audience booing)
(bell ringing)
- The winner by unanimous
decision, Art Chafee.
(audience booing)
- What kind of a double-cross is this?
Let's start out with a tiger
and wind up with a pussycat.
- From here on in, that's
the way I'm fighting.
- Oh no it's not, not
for us or anybody else.
I don't need you to play pattycake.
If I want this kind of a battle
I can get a better one right
out of an old maid's home.
(gentle music)
- Angelo.
Let me lug this.
I watched you go the distance tonight.
The way you fought,
you ain't strong enough
to carry this gear.
- I keep my face
and the crowd gets their
money's worth booing me.
- Your face looks alright.
Maybe a little on the sad side.
- Have you seen Emily?
- Like I told you, she left town to teach.
- Have you seen Father Callahan?
- He don't ask me about you.
What I could tell him he
reads in the sports column.
- Come on, Angelo, we split a steak,
then we split a pool table.
- [Hal] I say get rid of him.
We lost 10 G's on him last night.
- My advice is to wait,
this boy's in love with his new face.
- Then cut it up, 10
G's worth and dump him.
- I still say wait.
- [Hal] For what?
- For a killing, that's for what.
- What are you driving at?
This kid wants to be a
cover boy, not a champ.
- Now you got him pegged
wrong, he's good for a killing.
- When?
- Look, let him fight four or five times
as a defensive boxer.
He'll lose every body,
he'll be outboxed, out-classed,
but he'll go from an odds-on
favorite to a longshot.
The odds will get better
and better for us.
- If there's a payoff.
- There will be, once he goes back
to his old style of fighting.
Why one big bop with him as a killer,
we're bound to clean up.
- Say that's not bad, not bad at all.
How you gonna make him fight
his old way, even once?
- I'll find a way.
- Well we'll ride with you
but you're carrying the load from here in.
- I'll handle it.
- There'd better be a payoff.
- Okay teacher you don't
have to draw us a diagram,
we take your word for it,
but just to keep it friendly
you're gonna chip in with us.
Doug and I are putting
up ten grand a piece
and you're gonna put up five grand.
- Me, 5000?
- Why not?
If you're really sold on this operation
you can scrape it up.
- With monk going into that
fight at odds of seven to two
you shouldn't even stop to think it over.
- All right, count me in.
- Let me tell you one thing teacher,
if something goes wrong
better buy yourself a new blackboard.
(gentle music)
- Why did you have me meet you here?
- I wanted you to see with your own eyes
what their striving for.
They've got big plans,
like plans to help every
kid in this neighborhood.
- Okay I'll chip in
but I don't want to run
in to Father Callahan.
- You won't.
He's out trying to raise money.
And so is Emily.
- Who told you about Emily?
- Monk, for what I'm gonna ask you to do
I had to know everything
about ya, everything.
- What do you want?
- Monk, you've heard me
pop off about big shots
and heroes before, you
know they don't impress me.
So what I'm tell you
must come from my heart.
Believe me, Monk, you've got
a chance to be a big man now,
big where it counts,
big in the eyes of Father
Callahan and Emily.
- What do I have to do?
- Give 'em that recreation hall
they're campaigning so hard for.
They've got their heart set on it
but they'll never get it
from pennies, and nickels, and dimes.
You can give it to them
on a silver platter.
- How?
- By fighting the Seattle
Wildcat the way I tell ya.
- You know how I've been fighting.
- Yeah I know, but that's got to change.
Look, win this fight and
the whole purse goes to
St. Dominic's, our end too.
This is a fair deal.
I wouldn't lie to you,
you know that, not here.
You fight and I manage,
this is for a good cause.
- Where do you and the syndicate come in?
- The odds you'll be fighting at,
we'll do very well with side bets.
- You really think this will square me?
With Father Callahan and with Emily?
- I know it will.
Why this is bigger than penances,
it's even bigger than lip service.
You're saying you're sorry
the only way that counts.
I'll vouch for it Monk.
You fight my way
and you'll be okay with
the Father and Emily.
Now what do you say?
(audience chattering)
- Sure everything is okay?
We got the money spread out.
- Yes I'm sure,
besides you've got me for a deposit.
- Maybe you ought to give
him some final instructions.
- No the kid hates me,
I'd just irritate him.
Anyhow Angelo handles him better.
(door knocks)
- [Gym Worker] You're up next.
(audience shouting)
- [Audience Members] Boo.
- [Audience Member] Knock him out!
- He never wanted me to see him fight.
- You didn't come here
just as an onlooker.
You're here to help him with your thoughts
and your prayers.
- [Audience Member] Oh, here he comes.
(audience applauding)
(audience shouting)
(bell ringing)
- This is the main event of the evening.
10 rounds of boxing.
In this corner at 164 and a half pounds,
Kid Monk Baroni.
(audience booing)
And in this corner, at 165 pounds,
the Seattle Wildcat.
(audience cheering)
The referee Jack Stony
and may the best man win.
(audience booing)
- I want a good, clean fight.
Keep your punches up.
Now shake hands and come out fighting.
(buzzer dinging)
- [Audience Member] Come on boys.
(bell ringing)
(audience shouting)
- Get him, Monk, get him!
(bell ringing)
- [Audience Member] Come on, Monk!
- He's coerced tonight.
- You wear him down, I'll tell ya.
He can't take it anymore.
- He hits like a bull.
- Yeah but every time
you nick him in the puss,
he's hurt double.
Keep after his face.
(bell dings)
(audience shouting)
- [Audience Member] Come on, Monk.
(bell ringing)
(audience cheering)
- He's certainly taking a beating.
- Yeah and so are we.
If he doesn't come up with a
Sunday punch, we lose 20 G's.
- He will.
You don't know how much that kid
wants to spare himself,
(buzzer dinging)
a knockout will do it.
(audience chattering)
(bell ringing)
(audience shouting)
- One, two, three, four, five, six,
seven, eight.
Come on.
- [Audience Member]
Hold him on the ground.
(audience shouting)
- [Referee] Easy.
(audience cheering)
(somber music)
- What a windup.
We lose 20 G's.
We haven't even got a piece of the purse.
- Cleaned me out too.
- What are you moaning about?
If it hadn't been for you,
Hal and I would of never
get roped into this mess.
(somber music)
- Well at least the
losers end of the purse
goes for a good cause,
that recreational hall at St.
Dominic's, that's something.
- Oh, stop your corny philosophizing,
remember what I told you
about finding yourself a new blackboard
if something went wrong,
something went wrong.
(somber music)
- Hello Father.
- I lost, I lost.
- No my boy you didn't lose.
This was not defeat, you're
a bigger man for the trying,
for the sacrifice.
The way you fought
carries its own victories.
Look at the wounds on your
face, don't say you lost.
- Hello, Paul.
- Paul, we'll take you
home when you're ready.
I've heard rumors that the big gamblers
lost money betting on you.
Well you fought your fight
and if need be there's a few
good fast rounds left in
me and a hard left jab.
Just a reminder that our recreation hall
opens on the 10th of next month.
It is yours, young and old alike.
Come and enjoy it
and it is to one of our own sons,
a boy from this very street
to whom we all owe so much for making
this recreational center
possible so soon, Paul Baroni
and I am very happy to announce
that he and his lovely bride Emily
will be working with us when they return,
working with us to make
this a better street,
a better Church, and a better
community in which to live.
(gentle music)
(playful music)
(joyful music)